[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa vue des loulous désolé je suis pas
réveillé ah merde j'ai oublié de mettre
le filtre
avant ça marche je suis content j'ai
quand même une meilleure gueule
[Rires]
ca
oh
[Applaudissements]
gastou des
belles-mères france
one by name string
manie manirakiza
aumale avait absorbé une forte
[Musique]
et
je suis à la production en train de lire
mon courrier quand vous m'envoyez du
courrier essayé de privilégier des
enveloppes des courriers dans dedans
parce que là en fait je ne peux pas lire
le 1
le courrier est inaccessible dans la
bouteille voilà
une fois je suis tombé sur un gars il
tend break dance je pense j'ai désolé
monsieur jeu ça m'intéresse pas mais bon
ça même pas quand je vais vous parler
quand tu parles vous savez même pas vous
dis dieu vous vous dites vous savez pas
ce que je vais vous dire mes mecs mais
le cam allemand je suis par contre tu eu
consensus le savez la salle à partir tu
m'appelles mercredi jour des enfants
étudiants ne savais pas ce que tu me
proposez quoi une playstation 5 c koi tu
as proposé c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est
quoi c'est quoi c'est quoi et j'étais
vraiment comme ça mieux
un moment donné je suis merde [ __ ]
c'est un canular d'une radio ils m'ont
ils m'ont baiser moi comme ça un vrai
visage de bachoter jantes et j'ai
vraiment entendu quelqu'un faire
merci monsieur revoir pas il a raccroché
soldats qui donnait dans l'open space ça
me saoulait je le lis pas je laisse le
vais là-bas ça soulagerait pas ce que je
vais vous dire ça tourne ça libérera pas
alors la fibre avec bouygues